vous savez à quoi on reconnaît le plus
grand espion du monde leinster tout le
monde connaît son nom
[Musique]
soyez pas mauvais perdant vous avez pu
rencontrer les nostalgiques
merci merci retournez travail retourner
travailler vous en fait beaucoup trop si
probablement pas beaucoup trop mais
retourner quand même travaillé
d'austérité je vois sur un truc chez moi
tu va révolutionner l'espionnage
définitivement ça s'appelle la
dissimulation biodynamique imaginer que
j'arrive à vous faire attention
attention roulements de tambour
disparaître laisse paraître
puis disparaître pourquoi tu dis ça
comme ça bourg et les faits et ce
dispositif de dissimulation nouvelle
génération tu l'aurais pas sous la main
par hasard ben en fait je lai en main
ils peuvent avoir pâti si je peux vous
offrir un verger de l'eau des substituts
de repas ni voilà j'ai bu un verre se
coupe pas un arrière goût bizarre
bon alors ton truc high tech
[Musique]
ça marchera
sujets sont désorientés walter qu'est ce
que tu as fait les haines se regarde moi
ce que je te regarde je peux pas ne pas
regarder
walter je vois mes fesses et ton visage
en même temps puis il ya des pigeons
partout et personne ne les remarque
c'est ma cocotte ou un espion si le
camouflage idm intérêt à me descend
volailler et tout de suite ça suffit
maintenant je m'amuse pas d envoi les
choses le ton là je devrais probablement
pas hausser le temps walter il faut que
tu me disant voilà vous êtes envoyé tout
seul